[Music]
don't worry about supercuts now don't
worry about it i got a little bit more
for you as a cutaway for wave
yeah okay i got i got one for you i got
one for you
so uh a few weeks ago they went on
flagrant
uh the trash tuesday girls and here's
what happened sex with your brother oh
god that up again did you have sex with
your brother oh god
i possibly but i did have sex with my
step-brother
this should be easy merch ask me if i
have sex with my brother have you had
sex no are you [ __ ] crazy or even in
a regular site if you had sex with your
sister no you [ __ ] crazy it's very
easy you see how easy that is
let's see but let's see what she said
again i just want to hear make sure i
heard this right did you have sex with
your brother oh god
i possibly but i did have sex with my
stepbrother
wait possibly possibly but
definitely [ __ ] your step brother
what did she mean
well that's fine let's let's i've
already seen the clip so i haven't it
was sent to me i haven't seen it i find
out okay oh i thought you sent it to me
yeah i did because somebody sent it to
me and i sent it so we'd had it for prep
oh the schizophrenia he has since passed
away he uh
killed himself
all right pray because he [ __ ] his
sister whoa
homegirl like giggled at that
dude
oh my god she's your favorite oh my god
are we gonna turn around on this chick
are we gonna have are we gonna have a
turnaround on esther here by the end of
this
all right i'm backing up are you ready
you ready here we go stepbrother
um he has since passed away he
killed himself
r.i.p he was a victim
okay you know what what's going on here
i don't know
but i'm starting to turn around on old
esther here i love her it's an old jewy
lady name but
other than the old chewy lady name
i'm turning around on it esther is now
probably my favorite person in this
whole sphere
she's at lisa's top four now look at
schultz even looking at her going like
what is she why is she laughing
you know she laughed at her brother
[ __ ] killing himself
i like i like andrew schultz i think
he's funny
as far as as far as comedy podcast
sphere people go
this [ __ ] just shot up in the rankings
oh yeah from like you know
3046 all the way up to at least 200 in
the top 200 now holy [ __ ] man
i had sex with a boy who i was told
after i had sex with him that he could
potentially be my brother
doesn't that happen all the time
she's part filipino right
when that's frozen he would know they're
all related yeah
he does look like me we're we're never
going to wow let me be honest with you
the dna test because i don't think i'd
be able to handle that
um but there are whispers in the family
because our families are very close
could you imagine
getting your stepbrother's body exhumed
so you could have a dna test to find out
whether or not you [ __ ] your brother
and you're like can we just lay it to
rest you just leave it alone
and we sort of look at andrew schultz's
face though
oh no he's disgusted he's like what the
[ __ ] man
grew up together so a lot of filipinos
are related though
okay thank you he's right he's 100 right
original point thank you that you said
was racist so i don't want to know
and this is like you met as adults or
this was during like a child we grew up
together my his grand his dad
my dad and his grandpa were best friends
in the philippines i don't know what
they were doing in the 70s if they were
swapping partners but somehow i have a
family friend who looks exactly like me
and i had sex with him when i was 19.
because you're a narcissist
because if he looked exactly like you
you wanted to [ __ ] yourself
think about that for a second let's
really think for a moment here i'd
rather not no listen to me we're
listening we're going to talk about
incest real quick okay
we look i'm sorry but did listen
unfortunately
unfortunately
it has to be it has to be done it has to
be done unfortunately i dusted off the
45
incest
incest
[Music]
[Music]
for a whole year and then only later to
find out through his grandma
she was like wait like
you know there could be a chance
all the while everyone's like you guys
looking like each other
and we're like yeah that's probably
should [ __ ]
imagine meeting someone that looks like
you'll be like i need to [ __ ] that
person because they look like me [ __ ]
i am hot
i want to [ __ ] myself
yeah
it happens when people date they end up
looking like each other but we really do
look like each other
but you also look like blaire white i
mean look i'm just saying
and a puerto rican hula yeah i really
want to see you and
okay i [ __ ]
i'm with him you know i do too right i'm
not i really want to see what this guy
looked like
i know
yeah dude
and can we look at it worst of all is
that like
that's what's something about him you
know i found him attractive you know
they say like you are like repulsed by
your own like
it was not a pheromone match i remember
feeling like i didn't like the way he
smelled you [ __ ] your brother and you
know oh my god but then you didn't like
the way you felt but you [ __ ] him
probably more than once
she did [ __ ] him more than once oh she
did it definitely [ __ ] her brother
so
these pheromones that nature was telling
you not to but you love yourself so much
that you decided
ukulele to [ __ ] yourself
wow that's so cool sounds like a star
trek episode like you're [ __ ] your
male self
no the way he smelled like was there
like uh
[Laughter]
i
it's a metropolis yeah manila is one of
the biggest cities in the western world
andrew that's a good point smelled a
girl's breath and either been super
attracted to it or super unattracted to
it
no
[ __ ] little jewish weirdo her breath
no do you mean her tits sure yeah
but all right you got it but guys you
gotta remember that they breed different
you know they look for differences they
look for different signs why does she
always look like she's over at a
sleepover she's always like sitting like
she should be playing that telephone
dating game that board game
it's like she's getting ready to braid
each other's hair yeah seriously
[ __ ] when stiff as a board
that's like what we're kind of yeah but
that's mostly if they if they've uh
cleaned their mouth
or or
no it's probably the bruster teeth i'm
gonna lean on that side it's just not
your biological match what the f what
new age
[ __ ] horse [ __ ]
have they drilled into these [ __ ] la
comedians but that's why you get like
the occasional like andrew schultz well
i thought i'd just show to new york no
am i wrong um i'm pretty sure he's in
l.a
[Music]
i'm almost positive because new york
that is new york all right so
yeah then that's what it is it's the
clash yeah of
that's why he actually has discussed on
his face yeah that's why so and then you
have some of the people that do go to la
and like
when you see them at first versus where
they stay there for like 10 years when
they first are there doing a podcast
they have like stories like this coming
on and they're always like
ah there's always a weird like i don't
know there's something about the east
coast that's always been more
like openly expressive about like we're
very reactive to sure so we don't have
like the
like new york does but like the upper
west side jewie types but most of us
just
express our disgust
you mean like patrice did with anthony
that one time that [ __ ] murdered me
oh
my god you're disgusting which one the
whole is like how you how young oh that
yeah
butchery he actually said you should you
should be hung you [ __ ] a piece of [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] i don't know if that's
breath yeah i think that's a little bit
more like the body odor i think is so do
you like some women's body odor and some
you don't i don't want to say like i
don't really notice do you notice that
but like i mean they smell bad that's
different but i'm just saying like
general body odor it's more tolerable
it's like uh see i've got guys who
literally will put their nose and just
take the biggest whip you would you
would of course you would because like i
said you're a [ __ ] wes anderson
character that's what sanderson
something that would happen yeah luke
wilson
would be going out with her and he'd be
they seem to be laying in a whimsical
bed who who are you dating [ __ ] molly
shannon's character on snl
like what is that's not normal
okay yeah there are i mean there are
pheromones
connected
to
like the same places that basically your
body odor comes from if you're clean
and you're not covered in an axe body
spray and deodorant
you will have a certain amount of
natural pheromones you give off and that
is a science and do people are attracted
by those
but they're they're confusing like the
pheromone part with just stinking yeah
like smelling like no i don't want to
smell like there is a subtle pheromone
thing that does radiate off of you
that like you know you shower and like
you're super clean but then like an hour
later if you're out and about
you start having these pheromones but
she's like no smell my armpit i haven't
showered all day like oh that's [ __ ]
disgusting [ __ ] weird take a shower
because they're it's a pheromone match
yeah i get that
you want to go no not on you
got denied
wow she got denied
i'm sure it's flowers or daisies or
whatever do you do have you spoken to
him since um
yeah
okay another question i've always wanted
this
was it like a like a lego
oh there's that there's husband dick and
then there's brother big brother brother
jake might be is it like
exactly the amount like did you guys
lock in and go oh [ __ ] like yeah like
yeah
honestly like avatar like avatar but he
did kind of [ __ ] like me
he did [ __ ] you like you yeah a little
bit
in what way and i didn't like it hey
these people are broken dude they're all
broken is there another way to say it
and they're broken they're all broken
and you know what when the whole [ __ ]
collapses
these people are gonna fall first oh
yeah i mean they're just gonna get eaten
alive
he just like there was a clashing of
energies there it's like it wasn't
because it wasn't a biological match and
i remember like
yeah getting the feminine the jingies
after did he also
the what it's uh that's a filipino word
um for the feeling you have after you
[ __ ] your brother
frozen are you listening is that true
tell me just dm me if it's true we'll
get on all fours after until you die
okay that's the jesus christ